هول قرايبنا منرفع واحنا ما نخوش جبدنا
[موسيقى]
ويل والله الحمد لله على
السلام جع من رفح ل خانيونس ماخط الراس
هنا خانيونس مستشفى ناصر ماخط الراس هنا
انا بدي اروح اجيب نسوان ودي جوا وكنيات
واجيب لنا شغلنا يا خال تقع لعبت الدبابات
كله الصبح بن واجي وقفوا ه في نص الشارع
تطخ على الناس شردوها ه رجعوا على اخر
موقع
الات في الطريق اخر القادسيه وين كنت احنا
مهاجرين على
[موسيقى]
البحر لا حول ولا قوه الا
بالله
[موسيقى]
هذا
هو يا
[موسيقى]
زلمه
[تصفيق]
احمد داخل احد المنازل دخلها
الاان واحرقها
بالكامل
هيها في شايفه ا جراف
عل
وا كان في طخ وكان في قصف وكانوا اليهود
محصر نا كانوا قبالنا في يعني اي حد يطلع
في الساحه يقنص عليه قنصه ثلاث شباب كانوا
يجيبوا لنا اكل و يعني شرب انا من جبالي
انا جوزي شهيد ومعي تسعه اطفال ماليش حد
يعني
[موسيقى]
هنا
تعيده